- Have you ever had any
wardrobe malfunctions?
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh, yes.
- Yeah, I did too, I've had one.
What was yours?
- Jenna's is really good.
- Okay, so at the 40
Year Old Virgin premiere,
I had this dress, it was a lace dress
that had like, a
turquoise slip underneath,
and then it had a big sash
that came down the front.
- Yeah.
- And before I did the red carpet,
I had to use the restroom,
and Angela said, "Don't pee on the sash!
Don't pee on the sash!"
- [Angela] I was so worried
about the sash going in the toilet.
- So I held the sash up.
- Yeah.
- And then I rushed out to the red carpet,
and when I got inside and I took my seat,
I was like, "Why do I feel so
much of the seat on my tush?"
It was because I had tucked
the slip into my underwear,
and if you look at that picture.
- Look close.
- You can see my Target undies.
- [Angela] Yeah, look.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Jenna] You see the white spot?
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Those are my Target undies.
- But here's the thing,
it just looked like a
little gold lace trim
kind of going on right there.
- [Jenna] Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] It didn't look like that.
This, my favorite part is you
have no idea what's going on.
And you're just like, "Check out my ass."
- [Jenna] I'm like, they're
like, "Over the shoulder."
And I'm like, "You got it."
- They always yell at to me.
And I'm like, "You over the shoulder."
- I say, "No. I'm not doing that."
- It's not doing attractive.
I don't look good being
like, "Oh, this is casual."
Like, it's like, no.
- I was game. I was like,
"Sure. Over the shoulder."
- [Kelly] I think that's early on.
I was same earlier.
And I'm just like, "This is look, yeah."
- Yeah, that's all I got.
- That's what I do now.
I picked one pose.
This is the one pose I'm doing.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- At least your boobs
didn't almost pop out.
- Your boobs almost popped out?
- My boobs almost popped out.
"Hi mom."
- Wait, what? When?
- Okay, I got a fancy dress.
It was the year I finally,
someone gave me a dress.
I didn't have to go to the mall.
Because I did that a bunch of times.
So it had a train and I didn't
practice walking with a train.
And so what happened was,
I stepped on the train
and then I stood up.
And when I stood up, I was like,
"Why is my dress still down?"
And I kept going like this.
And then that happened.
And then a bunch of people
snapped and I grabbed my boobs.
- First of all, you look gorgeous.
- Oh, thanks.
- And yeah. I'm like,
"If they're falling out or
not, you look beautiful.
- Is that, did your heel?
My stiletto gets caught in the lace.
Is that what happened?
- That's what happened.
- [Kelly] That happens to me all the time.
It happened to me yesterday on this show.
I literally always, I
don't know what I do,
I like play with my feet down here.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Yeah.
- [Angela] Yeah, Well.
- But it happens.
- It happens.
And it's a moment that
you'll live with forever.
- I wore a dress one time.
It was so close.
It was so tight.
Like it looked good.
And it was like, I don't
know, close after Idol.
And I was like, "Oh, it looks so great."
And I was like, "God,
this is very fitted."
Right? And I had to get
a car to go or whatever.
I had to lay, I was laid down.
Just like, pretending
like life was normal.
They had to like, somebody
had to get me out of the--
and then I like proceeded
to like, mermaid walk down.
And I was like, "This is not me."
What are we doing?"
Anyway...